[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNA TAYLOR: So today,
we're super excited to have
Mary-Frances Heck with us.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Hello.
JENNA TAYLOR: Welcome to Google.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Thank you so much.
JENNA TAYLOR: Do you want to
talk about sweet potatoes?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Do I?
JENNA TAYLOR: I mean, all day?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: All day.
And in fact, for
the last 18 months--
JENNA TAYLOR: Literally.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: --I
went down a rabbit hole
and learned everything,
I think, there is
to know about sweet potatoes.
JENNA TAYLOR: So I've
been dying to ask,
and I want to, two things.
One--
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yep?
JENNA TAYLOR: --why?
And two, like, what are
we going to do here today?
I'm going to start with
that, but then please,
please, I must know why.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
So we're going
to do a little cooking demo
today of two savory dishes that
use really different flavor
profiles from one another
that hopefully give you a new
way to look at how to season
and how to cook sweet potatoes.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
marshmallows, brown sugar.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Tons
of marshmallows, as much
cinnamon as possible,
just pumpkin pie spice.
JENNA TAYLOR: No, that's
short cutting, right?
That's right to pumpkin pies.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Totally.
May there never be a
sweet potato latte.
Although I guess, you know--
MARY-FRANCES HECK: If
Starbucks heard you say that,
it's already on the menu.
JENNA TAYLOR: It might
be healthy, though.
Which leads me to why
I get really excited
about sweet potatoes, enough
to write a book about them.
So one thing is
that sweet potatoes
are incredibly nutritious.
They're even consider
a super food.
They're high in fiber,
high in vitamins.
The purple guys-- here, I'll
actually pass these around,
if you'd like.
The ones that have
purple flesh and or skin
are very high in an
antioxidant called
anthocyanins, which is the
same thing as in blueberries.
You know how
blueberries are supposed
to make you live forever?
So we have lots of
different colors here.
And I can cut more open,
but just so you can see.
And then the orange
ones have a lot
of beta carotene, which help
you see in the dark, obviously.
And the white ones are
for those who are just
entering into sweet
potato love, like
a good, gateway sweet potato.
JENNA TAYLOR: Gateway drug?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
And then from there--
so sweet potatoes,
and I'm sure you're all going
to fact check me on this--
in 2015, sweet potatoes were
the number two Googled recipe.
JENNA TAYLOR: Somebody,
please, know that that's true.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
And two notable things
about that, the number
one thing was pepitas.
And it is believed
in the food community
that that was because people
don't know what pepitas are.
JENNA TAYLOR: True.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
OK, and chicken
has always been the number
one searched for recipe.
Just, chicken recipes has
always been number one.
So chicken dropped to three
in 2015, as far as I know.
JENNA TAYLOR: What happened?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
OK, so people perceive
that sweet potatoes are
healthier, because they are.
But also diets like--
JENNA TAYLOR: Everybody knows
white potatoes are the devil.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Well, right, and we'll
get to that in a minute.
So sweet potatoes are allowed
by diets like Whole30 and Paleo.
And for those who
aren't actually
subscribing to those
diets, they hear things,
and then think they're going
to be doing good by doing
part of whatever, anyway.
So you have that one
component with diets.
The other component you have
is the sweet potato fry.
JENNA TAYLOR: Ah.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Which
has swept the nation.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Available at Burger,
if you're ever in Sunnyvale.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yeah, exactly.
So sweet potato
fries are elusive,
because they are never
going to be crispy, OK?
I tried.
We have a few recipes in the
book for sweet potato fries.
And you have to
actually-- whatever,
I'll get into that later.
But that's why they
were so searched for.
Because people are
trying to chase
a ghost of a crispy
sweet potato fry
that they will never be able
to recreate at home until now.
JENNA TAYLOR: Uh oh.
Sounds like you've solved it?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: There's
one solution, yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, I love it.
Can't wait.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
I have a few steps,
but yeah, you can get there.
So I think that's
why people got really
excited about sweet potatoes
and started Googling them.
And here we all are today.
And so my publisher--
JENNA TAYLOR: I love it.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
--we were talking
about a cool, single
subject cookbook.
And even though it's
now two years later,
it takes a little longer to make
a book than it does a website,
but so here we are.
And people are
still passionately
filling a room to learn
about sweet potatoes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, yeah.
You didn't miss the wave.
It's still going.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Oh, going strong.
JENNA TAYLOR: I love it.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Got a bit bigger.
JENNA TAYLOR: So what are
we going to make today?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: OK, so we're
going to make two recipes.
One is healthier
than the other, just
because of the amount
of butter in it.
JENNA TAYLOR: And that's totally
appropriate from a Google food
perspective.
We believe in the 80/20 balance.
So we'll give you
something good.
Give you something bad for you.
You need both in life.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
You don't have
to put these in, like, Skittle
jars, or opaque or something?
JENNA TAYLOR: No, we'll allow
the sweet potatoes to exist
outside of the frosted window.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Thanks, guys.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK, so--
JENNA TAYLOR: White
potatoes, frosted.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: I'm going
to explain what I'm doing here.
So this is a sweet potato.
It is not a yam, first of all.
JENNA TAYLOR: Anybody
know the difference?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: If
you know the difference--
JENNA TAYLOR: She has prizes.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
--you'll win a prize.
AUDIENCE: Yams are only
from a certain state.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yams are only from
a certain state, like bourbon?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
You are incorrect.
AUDIENCE: Ah!
JENNA TAYLOR: Ow!
MARY-FRANCES HECK: But you
are on the right track.
JENNA TAYLOR: Anybody
else want to wager?
AUDIENCE: Are yams from Asia?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yams
are from Asia?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: They are not.
But they are in Asia.
They're not
originally from Asia.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Anybody?
Anybody?
JENNA TAYLOR: Anybody else?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: This
is really a hard question.
OK, so when I bought these--
not these sweet potatoes,
but some sweet potatoes,
those sweet potatoes
at the store,
they were all labeled as
yams, which is incorrect.
OK, so in the 1930s, this
is where you are right,
the Louisiana sweet
potato growers
decided they wanted to market
the Beauregard sweet potato
different from their competitors
in Mississippi, North Carolina,
you know, elsewhere that
sweet potatoes are grown.
So they started calling them
yams, OK, just as, like,
a marketing idea.
Yams are a thing
that grow elsewhere,
they're not sweet potatoes.
So they just started calling
them yams, and it stuck.
JENNA TAYLOR: What's a yam?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So a yam--
so what a sweet potato
is is a root vegetable.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sure.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: OK, and
root vegetables carry fiber,
vitamins, sugar.
JENNA TAYLOR: You tell
me yams grow on trees,
I'm going to fall over.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah, so
yams also grow under the ground.
They're something
called a tuber.
You guys might be familiar
with another kind of tuber,
like a regular potato?
Solanaceous potatoes, I call
them, just for the distinction.
So sweet potatoes--
so yams are--
OK, so tubers
carry white starch.
That's an easy way
to remember it.
So white starch is
metabolized straight to sugar,
not good for you.
And in fact, once you
metabolize a potato,
it's a little bit more sugar
than a sweet potato ever
would be.
So you can taste the
sugar in a sweet potato.
You can't taste the sugar
in a potato or in a yam
until you metabolize it.
It's not converted to sugar.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sure.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: OK, so
a yam has a really dark
brown, bumpy, thick skin.
And it is creamy
white on the inside.
And it tastes, like, starchy,
like a regular potato or yucca,
kind of.
It's in the yucca, like,
not technically the family,
but whatever.
Anyway, so they are
not related at all.
And they're, in fact, different
anatomical parts of the plant.
They do both grow underground.
JENNA TAYLOR: Fascinating!
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
So there you go.
So this sweet potato--
JENNA TAYLOR: My
takeaway from that
is that sweet
potatoes are bourbon.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JENNA TAYLOR:
Regionally specific.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: You know
what I had last week was a sweet
potato vodka produced in--
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm listening.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
--North Carolina.
JENNA TAYLOR: I mean--
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
And they market it
as the best yam vodka on earth.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
also not made of yams.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Right?
Come on, guys.
OK, so what we're
going to make today,
the first recipe is a galette,
which is kind of like a tart.
And it's really easy
if you have a mandolin.
JENNA TAYLOR: And you
don't cut your finger off
with your mandolin.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yes, you definitely
should use a guard when you're
doing this unless you're
a trained professional.
So basically, what you do is
set it to about a quarter inch,
and then you take your sweet
potato, and you just slice it.
This is a really great tool for
cutting any kind of vegetable
into attractive and delicious
small slices, thin slices.
OK, so you have
your sweet potato.
And then we have
some puff pastry.
And this puff pastry is
about a one foot square,
about a 12 inch square.
And it is thawed,
because it comes
from the freezer, and
France, and from butter,
and a few other places.
But what I recommend doing--
JENNA TAYLOR: It's baby
angels from heaven.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
It's delicious.
It is not the same
as a croissant,
but it's kind of close.
So what you're going to do is
take your little sweet potato
slices and shingle them like so.
This would be a great
time for another question,
because it takes a minute.
JENNA TAYLOR: Anybody?
AUDIENCE: I've never seen a
sweet potato that large before.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: It's
a huge sweet potato.
JENNA TAYLOR: That sweet potato
reminds you of a football,
and you're wondering why.
Where does one find
football-sized sweet potatoes?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Usually in food service.
JENNA TAYLOR: Ah, we
get big everything here.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah,
big old bags of rice.
Bigger.
JENNA TAYLOR: Giant
sweet potatoes.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Bigger.
So these are some more
grocery store friendly size
of sweet potatoes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Actually, more--
MARY-FRANCES HECK: It's a baby!
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
a baby sweet potato.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
But you will find that
despite their different
sizes that they're
pretty much all the same.
If they're small,
or if they're large,
they're going to taste
pretty much the same.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, that
was what I was going to ask,
is their flavor kind
of profiles differing
from variety to variety?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Definitely
from variety to variety--
I like to classify
potatoes by color.
I think that's just the
easiest way to do it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sure.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: And by color,
I mean the color of the flesh.
JENNA TAYLOR: The insides.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yeah, the insides.
Because the skin can
be a little bit tricky.
And I'll cut some
more open in a minute.
But sometimes they can
be orange on the inside,
purple, or white.
And that's just easy to
not go further than that.
JENNA TAYLOR: So if the
grocery store mislabels them,
and the skin isn't
an indicator, how
does one divine the flesh
color of a sweet potato?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: OK, I'm not
officially recommending this,
but, like, scratch a tiny
little bit of the skin
off with your fingernail or
something in the grocery,
like, nick it.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Damage the produce.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
And you'll see.
So thank you, Mallory, for
displaying how to do that.
See, it's white.
Who knew?
A few more slices.
[MANDOLINE SCRAPING]
JENNA TAYLOR: Anybody else
have questions while we're--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JENNA TAYLOR: One
more time, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to
pick good sweet potatoes?
JENNA TAYLOR: Is there a way
to pick good sweet potatoes?
How do you not get a lemon?
Well, I mean, you don't buy an
actual lemon, but beyond that.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: That's
a different section
of the produce department.
OK, so a good sweet
potato will not
have any nicks or bumps
on the skin at all.
JENNA TAYLOR: So no one
should have scratched it
to see what the flesh color is.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: I said
I didn't recommend that.
JENNA TAYLOR: Check, I
think you did officially
recommend the scratch test.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: I officially
do not recommend this.
So what you want to
do is just make sure
that the skin is pristine.
It also should be
heavy for size,
which if you think about--
I think of water as
being heavy for size.
I don't think of, like, chilies
as being heavy for size.
You want make sure that--
occasionally, you'll
see that down the core
of the sweet potato,
it's a little spongy.
And what you don't want is that.
So if they feel lighter than
that you think they should,
don't buy them.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
heavy, unblemished.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: And don't
trust the signage about the yam
thing.
But do trust the signage
about the color thing,
because they usually are
pretty explicit about that.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK.
Like, purple sweet potato,
orange sweet potato.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: It's gonna
be purple on the inside.
That's what they're
talking about, OK?
So white potatoes-- they
might be tan on the outside,
but they're going to
be white on the inside.
JENNA TAYLOR: Got it.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Another
thing that's helpful
is if you're in a
Japanese grocery store
and you see a sweet potato that
has this white skin like this,
has this purple skin like this,
they're opposite on the inside.
JENNA TAYLOR: Only
in a Japanese market?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Typically--
no definitive things
with sweet potatoes, you never
know what's going to happen.
Also the Japanese sweet
potato, here's a bit of trivia.
Does anyone recognize this
from somewhere, just like this?
Anybody?
Do you know the answer?
AUDIENCE: Could it be an emoji?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
It's an emoji!
JENNA TAYLOR: Aw.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Anyway.
JENNA TAYLOR: I often wonder how
they decide which things should
and should not be an emoji.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Should
be an emoji, who knows?
JENNA TAYLOR: That's another
conversation entirely.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Entirely.
OK.
JENNA TAYLOR: All
right, shingles,
beautifully distributed.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Back to our galette.
So we are just going
to do a little bit of--
ooh, could I have
the bacon, please?
JENNA TAYLOR: Can't tell
you how many times I've
said that sentence in my life.
[BEEPING]
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Oh, stop it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
the oven is mean.
It doesn't care for me.
But that's OK.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
OK, so about a quarter
of a little onion or a
shallot, little allium action.
Sprinkle it over, just like
in the picture in the book.
You can do it.
OK.
And what else?
We'll put some thyme.
And with thyme,
don't worry if you
get little baby stems in there,
because it doesn't really
matter.
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm so glad you
said that, because picking--
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Picking thyme's horrible.
JENNA TAYLOR: Thyme is maybe
my least favorite kitchen
task of all time.
Every time anybody
wants to help me cook,
that's what they get to do.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Pick herbs.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
then they never ask me
if they can help me ever again.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
People are rough.
OK, sorry I'm moving
around so much.
So one handy thing to do with
bacon, and it worked really
well this time,
is if you're going
to cut bacon into little
pieces that we call lardons--
they're French-- put
it in the freezer
for, like, 15 minutes
before you try to cut it.
Because otherwise
it can be very soft
and your knife can
slip on the bacon,
and you can cut
yourself pretty badly.
See?
It worked great.
It's super firm.
And so once the bacon is
a little bit firmed up,
just cut it into
these little pieces,
and they're much
easier to cut, then.
AUDIENCE: Does that
affect cooking time?
JENNA TAYLOR: Does that
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Cutting the bacon?
JENNA TAYLOR: No,
freezing the bacon.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Freezing the bacon-- not
for something like this.
JENNA TAYLOR: Par
freezing, really.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yeah, I mean, you
can feel that if you
want to get gross.
But it's still kind of, I mean,
it's probably at 31 degrees.
It's not deep frozen.
OK.
So you sprinkle this over.
JENNA TAYLOR: Just
frozen enough to cut.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yeah, firm it up.
Same thing if you're ever
using salt pork or any kind
of cured, soft meat.
There you go.
JENNA TAYLOR: Pro tip, love it.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yep.
Any other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, if you're just
winging it, and not following
an exact recipe--
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Because
people do not do that.
AUDIENCE: --how do you
choose between whether to use
onion versus shallots?
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh,
how do you choose
between whether to
use onion or shallot?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So I
would use whatever I already
have in my kitchen.
JENNA TAYLOR: There you go.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
I love shallots.
It has a mild sweet flavor.
They have a mild, sweet flavor.
But they can be a
little trickier to find.
And red onion, for
something like this,
is a pretty comparable flavor.
OK.
So I think we have everything
on this-- ooh, a little salt
and pepper.
OK, this is really easy.
Everyone can do this.
And I want to see all of
your pictures on Instagram.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNA TAYLOR: Hash
tag sweet potatoes.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: And then you
magically put it in your oven.
And then it magically appears--
JENNA TAYLOR: In a different
oven right over there!
Look at that!
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
And it's just ever so
slightly different style.
Here you go.
And when it's-- so
when it's perfect--
JENNA TAYLOR: Amazing.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
It's the bacon.
JENNA TAYLOR: I know.
Well, it's the everything.
OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Here's what you get.
Yeah, it's a sweet
potato, totally.
So you get this
pretty little tart
that's perfect for when your
mom comes over for brunch.
And it only took you five
minutes to put together.
Ooh, and in fact, the point
where I just shoved it
in the oven, you can take that
whole thing, just like that,
and put it in the
refrigerator overnight.
So when you wake up, you have--
JENNA TAYLOR: Make
ahead, love it.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: For sure.
OK, so then this is
a fun thing to do.
You've probably had
a pizza like this.
First time cracking an egg.
That's a joke.
It's not my first time.
First time today, perhaps.
OK and then, so once
it's at this point,
you're going to see it's
puffed around the edges.
And it's light golden brown.
The sweet potatoes
are cooked through,
and the bacon is crispy.
OK, those are all
your little signals.
You crack an egg in the middle.
And then you put it back in
the oven for about six minutes.
Timer, anyone?
Could someone?
JENNA TAYLOR: OK, Google.
Set a timer for six minutes.
Done.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Is that real?
OK, good.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's how
we do everything here.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Great job.
Thanks, everyone, and Google.
OK, so while that's
doing its thing,
we're going to make
the next thing.
JENNA TAYLOR: And what
is the next thing?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
The next thing
is something I like to
call cracked sweet potatoes
with chilies and coconut.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, I'm liking
this list of ingredients.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
So we are going
to take one of my favorite food
groups, which is leftovers.
JENNA TAYLOR: I knew
I liked you so much.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: This is how
this dish actually came to be.
I had been working on a
book about sweet potatoes.
And I had a lot of--
JENNA TAYLOR: A bunch of
sweet potatoes, I bet.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: I had
a lot of roasted-- like,
I had been roasting
sweet potatoes all week.
And just till they were--
JENNA TAYLOR: Right.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Until
that recipe was correct.
When you're working with
purple sweet potatoes,
you might want to wear gloves.
Just because they're going
to turn your hands purple.
They could.
OK, so I opened my fridge.
I think I might have
had some friends
over for brunch or something.
And I think everyone was
feeling pretty much like they
were hungry.
And so I was, like,
what to feed people?
And there were the
sweet potatoes.
And I had a bunch of
herbs and some chilies
and then some pantry stuff.
And so that's where
this came from.
And this is a
technique that when
you have cold, leftover
roasted sweet potatoes.
They're not great for
anything except this.
They kind of crack.
They're not going to
turn into a nice mash.
But what they do
do well is crack,
and they're a little dry.
And they're, like,
you take something
that's kind of unappetizing,
and make it really appetizing.
JENNA TAYLOR: Are we making
sweet potato nachos right now?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Basically.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh my
god, so exciting.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
With Thai flavors.
JENNA TAYLOR: Could not be
happier about that outcome.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
OK, so one cool
thing about getting
a few colors of
sweet potatoes is
that they'll do all the
work for you in making
the plate look pretty.
So you just have to remember to
wake up, put them on a plate.
So, like I said, this is a
good breakfast or brunch dish.
But also it's great for
dinner, like next to a roast.
Or for your vegetarian
and or vegan friends
who are always hungry,
but never satisfied.
Am I right?
JENNA TAYLOR: Write
that one down, please.
It's going in.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah,
I live with a vegetarian.
So it's OK that I said that.
JENNA TAYLOR: We feed many
vegans and vegetarians daily.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: And I think
it's a really nice choice
for your life.
But I think that they're left--
those who are not partaking
in the meat stuff--
can get really hungry and never
feel like they've had enough.
JENNA TAYLOR: Truer
words never spoken.
AUDIENCE: So I saw
you were [INAUDIBLE]??
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So how
to peel a sweet potato--
once it's roasted,
oftentimes the skin
will be loose on the outside.
And you can just peel
it off like that.
You might want to wear gloves.
They can be a little
sticky, and like I
said, for the purple
ones, especially.
That said, if you just
had a paring knife
and you wanted to peel it off,
it usually comes off in strips.
It's pretty clean.
And if they've been
roasted correctly,
the flesh should have
dehydrated a little bit,
and therefore shrunk
away from the skin.
And so you're left
with a loose skin.
If you were to peel-- we didn't
actually peel the sweet potato
in front of you all.
But I would just recommend
a regular vegetable peeler.
And you could go
around once or twice,
depending on how many of
these little bumps and eyes
that you get.
You can also totally
eat sweet potato skins.
Some people just don't
love the texture.
And we could have the
skin in this dish as well.
I just don't love the texture.
Sorry, YouTube.
OK, so then you made a little
vinaigrette kind of a thing.
So far, this is what we've done.
JENNA TAYLOR: Beautiful.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Put
sweet potatoes on a plate.
Anyone can do this.
I hope.
OK, so get our
pan a little warm.
And we are going to melt--
this is coconut oil.
And once it melts, it's
going to smell really good.
JENNA TAYLOR: So tell me,
I was wondering earlier.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yes?
JENNA TAYLOR: Sweet
potatoes, are they seasonal
or can you really eat
them all year around?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
You can definitely
get them all year round.
And because of the way that--
JENNA TAYLOR: I know
you can, but should you?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: You should.
I think you should.
JENNA TAYLOR: Great.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
You should eat them every day.
You will find- OK-- so
they're harvested, truly,
let's say in October.
That's relatively true
for most of this country.
They are also harvested
in other parts
of the world at
different times of year,
just depending on
their growing calendar.
And so it is possible to find
relatively fresh sweet potatoes
all year round.
You also can find sweet potatoes
that are like a year old
and have that weird spongy
thing going on in the middle.
And so what I
recommend is if you're
between the months of like
July and that fresh season
of October, soon as you
get home with your bag
of sweet potatoes,
cut one in half.
And you'll see.
And if they're
lousy, return them.
Or you can eat
them, they're just
not going to be as delicious.
They are super shelf stable.
They are held in
storage facilities
that are going to keep them
fresh until they get to market.
I recommend not buying them more
than about two weeks before you
want to use them, because
they will have been out
of that storage facility and
sitting in a grocery store.
So also, when you get them
home, store them in a basket.
I think that's the perfect
thing to store them in.
They need to have
a little air flow.
You never want to let them
get wet or cold or too hot.
JENNA TAYLOR: Right in the
middle, not wet, not cold,
not hot, air flow.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Air flow.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
totally doable.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Just like a person,
like where a person wants to be.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's
what I was thinking.
I was like that's
pretty much how I feel.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
So we have melted--
JENNA TAYLOR: Our
six minutes is up.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
--thank you very much.
Melted coconut oil that's
not quite hot enough,
it should sizzle
when it hits the pan.
So I just threw some
ginger in there.
We'll give it a second,
and just like that.
I think we need one more minute,
one more minute on the egg.
OK, great, so it's sizzling.
And we'll add some
little rings of chilies.
And if you don't
like spicy food,
I recommend you don't
put chilies in this.
And we have some
scallion whites.
That's a cool thing you can do
when you're chopping scallions
is chop the white bulb,
essentially like the first four
inches near the root, take the
root off, slice that white.
Separate it from the green.
Use the white when
you're cooking,
and then use the
green as a garnish.
It's kind of a
simple thing to do
that can elevate your
food a little bit
at home, simple touch.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love it.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: OK.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Smells like heaven.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So we've
got our ginger, our chilies,
and our scallion whites
cooking in this oil.
And what you want to look
for is when they start,
the chilies and
the ginger, start
to become sort of translucent.
We don't really want
to brown anything.
We're just looking for them
to be soft, and really,
for all of their
beautiful aroma to have
been released into the room.
OK, and then you turn off
the stove because we're done.
See, that was super easy.
So for today's demo, we're
going to do it vegan style.
Ordinarily, I would use a little
bit of fish sauce in this dish.
Today we're going to a
little bit of soy sauce.
It's just a splash.
If you don't like
either of those things,
you can also just use
a large pinch of salt.
But it's value added
salt, basically.
And then we have some
brown sugar, again,
so that the dish remains
vegan, we could also use honey.
And once the sugar sort
of starts to dissolve,
we're going to add lime juice.
And that's what makes it
a citronette as opposed
to a vinaigrette.
And just give it a little stir.
And taste it.
You want this to be savory,
which means salt as opposed
to a lot of sugar.
OK.
So now we have our citronette
that has everything in it.
We're going to spoon it over
the sweet potatoes like so.
For a total of 30
seconds of cook time,
people might be impressed.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
visually stunning.
It smells amazing.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Hope it tastes OK.
JENNA TAYLOR: Hitting on
several important components.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
OK, so once you're
warm citronette
is on there, we're
going to dress it up
with some toasted coconut
and those scallion greens
that we kept separate
so they stay vibrant and
delicious and crunchy.
And then we're going to
tear a little mint over.
You could also use basil or Thai
basil, or any soft tender herb
that you have.
Cilantro would be
awesome in this, whatever
you have in the fridge.
JENNA TAYLOR: Truly,
truly beautiful,
I mean that's a stunning dish.
Especially, as you were saying,
for the vegan who might feel
neglected.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: The
sweet potatoes did, you saw,
all the work.
JENNA TAYLOR: All the work.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
OK, so there you go.
Great side dish, great any
time of day when you're--
JENNA TAYLOR: Gorgeous.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
--ripping it out
of the fridge because
you're starving.
JENNA TAYLOR: What do
you think about that egg?
Maybe done?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Hm, I
think you might be right.
Oh, yeah, OK.
So this is actually perfect, It
took a little bit longer than--
woo!
I need goggles.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Wow, guys.
OK, so what you want to see--
so our egg is now, essentially,
over easy, OK, from the oven.
What you want to see is the
white is still a little jiggly.
As it sits here and kind of
cools, it's going to firm up.
But your yolk will
still be runny.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well,
that's perfect.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Anybody
here not like eggs?
Just a question.
JENNA TAYLOR: I couldn't
tell by your face.
You looked like you
were super into it.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So
what's really appetizing
for many people is this thing.
When you have the egg yolk, and
it runs all over the place--
JENNA TAYLOR: You could, like,
take some on that pastry.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
--on to your tart.
JENNA TAYLOR: And dunk
it right in there.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Exactly, exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: Looks like
a really fantastic option.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So
there you have it--
two sweet potato dishes
that you know how to make.
JENNA TAYLOR: They're
gorgeous and amazing.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Set this up here.
JENNA TAYLOR: Did
you guys realize
that you get to eat some of
it, which makes it even better?
Super impressive-- I
think we're getting
close to being able to serve.
Do you guys have questions?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yeah, more questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So for
the nacho thing?
[LAUGHTER]
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm sorry.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
That's exactly, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you heat up the
sweet potatoes for it, or--
JENNA TAYLOR: Did you
heat the sweet potatoes?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
These sweet potatoes
are room temperature,
which I like.
But you could use this thing
called a microwave to heat them
up for about 30 seconds.
You can also like to
toss them in a pan.
It's just the pretty colors
will start to bleed together.
So it's nice to warm them
up separately, if possible.
Yes?
JENNA TAYLOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Adding
onto that question,
you said that those were baked.
Would you ever foil
a sweet potato?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yeah, absolutely.
JENNA TAYLOR: Would you
foil a sweet potato?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: If you'll
turn to the first chapter--
JENNA TAYLOR: [LAUGHS]
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
So the first chapter,
I sort of tried to address how
to cook sweet potatoes when
you want to cook them with no
other ingredients, for example.
It's called In The
Rough, which just
means all you're going
to use is a sweet potato
and occasionally, a
little bit of oil.
And so it overviews recipes
for how to roast them,
how to roast them in coals,
which I highly recommend.
Really, really delicious,
it kind of has that, like,
toasted marshmallow thing
without the marshmallow.
JENNA TAYLOR: Without
the marshmallows.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: No
marshmallows allowed.
JENNA TAYLOR: Because
you don't need them.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Mm hm.
But the caramel will start to
bubble out of the sweet potato
and char, oh, so good.
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm sold.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
And then boiled
potatoes, which you can then
turn into a sweet potato puree.
It's fine, also, to make sweet
potato puree roasting them
in the microwave,
which can be quick.
And some people don't
like microwaves.
I'm not one of those people.
I think that they
really make life easy,
especially when you're
cooking for a family.
So you roast them
in the microwave
for approximately five
minute increments,
for two or three increments, so
anywhere from 10 to 15 minutes,
depending on your microwave.
Then you scoop them
open, take the flesh out.
And then use the sweet potato
puree for eating or baking,
which we'll get
into in a second.
Are we OK on time?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
I don't really
know because I'm
having a good time.
And Laura, Laura will tell
me if we're good on time.
Yeah, we're good.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Flash.
OK, so then sweet potato fries.
And we kind of outline the
easy way and the hard way.
And the easy way is
just oven roasting, OK?
It's really easy.
JENNA TAYLOR: Not crispy?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
You can do it.
Sort of crispy for the
first five minutes, ish.
Yeah, it's very satisfying.
JENNA TAYLOR: Crispy adjacent.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: A quick
side dish, I highly recommend.
JENNA TAYLOR: Fair enough.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
I highly recommend.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
then the hard way?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
The hard way involves
cutting them, freezing
them, and then dipping them
into a cornstarch slurry, which
is a dissolved, modified food
starch.
And what that does, where sweet
potato fries or sweet potatoes
don't have the same
amount of starch
as white potatoes or
Solanaceous potatoes,
it provides the
starch on the outside
of the fry to get that crunch.
It's essentially sort of
like a tempura batter,
but it's really thin, and
it just coats the outside.
They also will stay
crispy for like an hour
after they're cooked.
JENNA TAYLOR: That is amazing.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
You have to fry.
Get over your fear of frying.
You can do it.
Open a window, though, if
you're in an apartment.
JENNA TAYLOR: Put on a fan.
Open a window.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
Which brings me next to chips,
which are very tasty as well.
Very easy to make, and
way better than anything
you can buy.
JENNA TAYLOR: Noted.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yeah, way better.
You soak them in
water, ice water,
which helps to sort of equalize
every slice of sweet potato,
washes off any surface starch.
And then dry them and deep fry
them, and they're really great.
JENNA TAYLOR: So many thoughts.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
I could go on.
JENNA TAYLOR: You could go on.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: OK,
so purple potatoes,
something about chips
with purple sweet potatoes
is that they're
also really good.
But the pigment that makes
sweet potatoes purple
is water soluble.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So
we're talking about--
JENNA TAYLOR: You can
wash away the purple?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: You can
wash away the purple, yes.
And it's not cute
while it happens.
It's kind of a gray
purple thing that happens.
It's really gross.
So if you tried to just
boil purple sweet potatoes.
The water would turn purple.
The sweet potatoes would
bleed out some of their color.
And it's just kind of sad.
You have this
beautiful vegetable.
Showcase it the
best way possible.
JENNA TAYLOR: Seriously.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
You can roast them
whole like this, where they're
just cooked in their jackets,
and they're not in
contact with any water.
JENNA TAYLOR: I really like
that you just said jackets.
Sweet potato got a
cute pea coat for fall.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Actually,
if you go to Ireland--
or one time, I went to
Ireland, and I ordered potatoes
in their jackets.
And they were just boiled
little baby new potatoes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Cutest
menu item ever.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Great way to call them.
So but deep frying-- so if
you slice the sweet potatoes,
even though you're
soaking them in water,
they'll still have
enough pigment.
And then you fry
them, you have these,
like, incredible purple chips.
So fun, so easy to
make for a party.
You can dust them with
curry powder or something,
really, really tasty.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Mentally taking notes.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So after
you've boiled your orange sweet
potatoes or white ones,
sometimes, you can mash them,
and take the resulting puree--
and if you'll turn
with me to page 105,
there's a whole chapter
on how to make bread
with sweet potatoes,
Breads and Baked Goods.
So you have biscuits,
babka, waffles, I mean--
JENNA TAYLOR: Stop.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
--you could go on.
JENNA TAYLOR: I mean.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Sticky
buns, cinnamon rolls,
dinner rolls, highly
recommend for Thanksgiving,
yeah, like this.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, pull
apart and everything.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
So yeah, you can
do a lot with sweet potatoes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Clearly, I mean,
I think you've proven that.
How is it, delicious?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
[WHISPERING] Is it OK?
JENNA TAYLOR: Everybody
got super quiet,
and that's always the best
sign when the food's around.
And does anybody else, yeah?
Question?
How do you avoid the
misbranding yam scam?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yep.
That's exactly what it is.
It's a yam scam.
JENNA TAYLOR: See
what I did there?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
So today I was
going to bring you a yam so that
we could look at them together
and realize that they
are, in fact, not
at all related visually.
I couldn't find one.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's
what I was going to say.
Are they really present
in most grocery stores?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: I went to
six grocery stores yesterday.
JENNA TAYLOR: So,
no is the answer.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: I went
to everything from Safeway
to a Japanese grocery store
to a Latino grocery store.
You could maybe find them
in a Caribbean grocery
store, which I didn't find
a Caribbean grocery store.
JENNA TAYLOR: The
only place I've
seen a true yam is
the Berkeley Bowl.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: There you go.
Yeah.
Or maybe--
JENNA TAYLOR: But they have
all of the things, so--
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
I found yucca and a couple
other sort of similar tubers.
JENNA TAYLOR: So risk is low.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Risk is low.
JENNA TAYLOR: Of
getting yam scammed.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Point being, when
you go to the grocery store
and sweet potatoes are
labeled as yams, don't worry.
You have not purchased a yam.
JENNA TAYLOR: I
feel pretty safe.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: I
think it'll be OK.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: They'll never
be in a typical grocery store,
or not yet, maybe in the future.
JENNA TAYLOR: Anything else?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JENNA TAYLOR: Are
different sweet potatoes
better for different
applications?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Yes, absolutely.
So that's a great question.
And I'd point your attention
to the introduction
for a little bit more
further explanation.
But I had mentioned
before that I typically
think of sweet potatoes by
color, color of their flesh.
And you'll find that orange
sweet potatoes typically
have more moisture inherent
than white sweet potatoes
or purple sweet potatoes.
And so they're really great.
So when you think of a high
moisture or a low moisture
item, you want to cook
it the opposite way.
So you want something
to be-- especially
if you want something to
be moist and toothsome
and have a great texture
when it's done cooking,
unless you're frying,
which is a different thing.
But I really love to roast
whole orange sweet potatoes just
to have as a side dish.
If you roast a
purple sweet potato,
you'll actually get more of what
you're eating right now, which
is a little bit dry.
It's almost-- I think
it's almost the flavor
and the texture of a chestnut.
It's leaning more in that
really toothsome, almost dry,
but not unpleasantly.
So I think that I love
purple sweet potatoes
baked in their jackets for
this type of application.
But if you wanted
to get a puree,
I'd suggest cooking them
in tiny little bit of water
with a lid jammed on it.
And they'll essentially
steam, and that's a great way
to do it, so steaming them.
And then white sweet
potatoes are awesome.
They're quite dry.
We don't actually
have one here today.
We have a sample of one.
I'm going to cut these open
so you can see the insides.
White sweet potatoes
tend to be quite dry.
And I really love
them in braises.
This is a sweet potato.
And this is a variety
called Hannah.
And it's a palindrome,
H-A-N-N-A-H.
And the variety you'll find
on the East Coast is usually
O'Henry.
There are a hundred varieties
of sweet potatoes at least.
So don't worry if you don't
know their exact names.
This is a garnet.
And so you'll find the
rusty red typically
leads to orange flesh,
except for in the case
of the Japanese sweet potato.
So as you can see, the
flesh is really similar,
but the skins are very
different from one another.
I'm just going to keep walking
around time to kill time,
you know.
There you go.
And then, yes, so
white sweet potatoes
and Japanese sweet potatoes
are wonderful braised.
So I love cooking them with--
I think our first tart's done.
Look at that.
So you can cook them
in a flavorful liquid.
I love cooking them
with sausage and beans.
And a braise would mean
about that much liquid
in the bottom of a pot with
other flavorful things.
And the white sweet potatoes
absorb the flavor beautifully.
And you'll find that if
you try to substitute
orange sweet potatoes
in that recipe,
there's a recipe for
braised sausage and lentils,
that the orange sweet potatoes
are going to absolutely fall
apart in a braise.
White sweet potatoes
will keep their shape,
and they'll become almost
silky, really nice.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JENNA TAYLOR: Is the
canned yam a yam?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to guess no.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
So a fun fact,
as someone who's
now written a book
about sweet potatoes, the
first sweet potato I ever ate
was from a can.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh!
MARY-FRANCES HECK: And
I strong armed my dad
into buying them
for Thanksgiving.
He was, like, we don't--
like, it's not part of
their family lexicon
to have sweet
potatoes, or foodicon--
JENNA TAYLOR: OK.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: --to have
sweet potatoes at Thanksgiving,
because my family is
not from the South.
So it's one of those
typical recipes
that you find that's like an
heirloom recipe for casseroles
and pies.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: And so,
yes, my first sweet potato
was a canned yam.
But my recipes are not
Southern based recipes.
They're really how
to incorporate them
into the way we eat now.
And they're not--
you could certainly
serve some of these dishes
during the holidays.
But the intention
is not that they
are for the holidays--
for every day.
JENNA TAYLOR: Awesome.
So the canned yam, not a yam?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Sweet potato,
not a yam, a sweet potato.
JENNA TAYLOR: The
yam scam continues.
[LAUGHTER]
Even in canned products.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] butter?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Butter.
JENNA TAYLOR: What's the best
fat to make them super creamy?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
I love butter.
JENNA TAYLOR: Every
bit of the butter.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Sweet
potatoes love butter.
JENNA TAYLOR: They told me.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
There's a sidebar
in there somewhere
that literally
is, like, sweet
potato hearts butter.
And it's wonderful with
coconut oil, I think.
And anything else that
has inherent flavor.
I'm not the craziest about
olive oil with sweet potatoes.
Like a really good
extra virgin olive oil,
save that for regular potatoes.
I think sweet potatoes
have a lot of--
JENNA TAYLOR: Or don't eat
regular potatoes, either way.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Oh, I
mean, whatever you want.
Oh, here's a good one, too.
So regular potatoes
are often grown using
a large quantity of chemicals.
They're part of
conventional farming,
so they have either
herbicides or pesticides.
There are a couple of
bugs that really love
to eat Solanaceous potatoes.
And you know, just in order
for there to be a crop,
it needs to have some chemical
intervention, which I mean,
sometimes we all do.
JENNA TAYLOR: I mean.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: So
it's not a great habit
to be in to eat,
particularly like russet.
And I'm not downing
any kind of food.
I love potatoes.
I wrote a whole column
about potatoes, obsessed
with potatoes personally.
JENNA TAYLOR: Do
sweet potatoes know
you cheated on them
with white potatoes?
[LAUGHTER]
MARY-FRANCES HECK: White
potatoes came first, OK?
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh!
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
But sweet potatoes
can be grown without much
chemical intervention.
They don't have a ton of natural
pests in the wild, so to speak.
That is changing a little
bit due to monoculture.
But if you look at these lists,
like the Clean 15 and the Dirty
Dozen, typically, potatoes
tend to be on the Dirty Dozen
and sweet potatoes tend
to be a Clean 15 product.
Which is great for a
socioeconomic approach
to good eating, because
you don't have to seek out
organic sweet potatoes.
You can just buy regular sweet
potatoes and save the buck.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
they're a superfood
that is naturally low
in a type of pesticides
and really affordable
for everybody.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Really
affordable for everybody.
And so I think it's one of
the superfoods that, you know,
we hear about all
these different things.
But they're really
expensive for the most part.
It's really hard to
incorporate super foods
in your everyday diet.
And so that's why I feel
very passionately, also,
about people eating sweet
potatoes, learning about how
nutritious they are, and then
being able to incorporate them
every day.
JENNA TAYLOR: Can we call in
the sweet potatoes' publicist
and have them, like, hype the
superfood angle a bit more?
Because I feel like
this is the first time
I've actually heard that.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Really, yeah.
I mean, and I think,
in particular,
the purple sweet potatoes
are one of the most
nutritious things you can eat.
I mean, of all the things
that come right out of a plant
or out of the ground,
they're super nutritious.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, that's
great piece of information.
I really do hope that that
gets more widely understood.
Because--
MARY-FRANCES HECK: And one
more cool thing about why
they're so healthy--
so sweet potatoes are
really high in fiber,
which is great for
diets that are for folks
who have diabetic diets or
maybe high cholesterol or heart
issues.
So they're trying to eat
more fiber, which helps to--
the best way to
describe it, like,
everyone's, like,
eat more fiber.
You're, like, why?
Because it kind of slows
down and evens out digestion.
So when you eat a bunch
of food, 'cause you only
have a little time to grab
lunch, delicious as it may be,
your insulin will spike, right?
But the more good stuff that
you eat that has fiber in it,
and I'm not talking
about Metamucil,
I'm talking about
foods with fiber--
JENNA TAYLOR: Naturally
occurring, organic fiber, yeah.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: --although
get it, get it where you can.
But sweet potatoes
have the ability
to kind of even out digestion.
And so you're not
having an insulin spike,
and then a crash later on.
You'll find that after having
a meal with a sweet potato
as a side dish, or any of
these 60 recipes in this book,
that you kind of feel
even keeled afterwards.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sustained energy.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Yeah, that's great.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's
important, I think, especially.
We think about that a lot
here, because we feed you lunch
and then need you
to go be geniuses
for the second half of the day.
So sustained energy is
really, really important.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah,
yeah, they're great for that.
JENNA TAYLOR: Awesome.
Any more questions?
I feel like I learned a
shocking amount today.
I don't know if you guys agree?
Oh, well, thank you.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JENNA TAYLOR: Do you
have a favorite kid?
MARY-FRANCES HECK: OK.
So as most parents
will tell you, yes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Ah ha, we
won't tell you which one,
but we will admit we have one.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: I think one
of the cool recipes in this
book that just-- sort of,
I learned a lot while I was
cooking through the recipes--
is some of the baked goods.
It's really
interesting to see what
mashed sweet potato or grated
sweet potato can add to a dish
without overtly
being sweet potatoey.
So you can add it
to the bread dough,
for example, make the
rolls, or a sandwich loaf.
It'll stay fresh for three
or four days just sitting
on your counter top.
It's a beautiful orange color.
It's very appetizing looking.
It tastes and feels like
a Martin's potato roll,
so it has that squish factor.
And the sweet potato
naturally works sort of
like a dough conditioner.
And so you have this really
nice texture that normally you'd
only get from a commercial
bakery where they have access
to some of the ingredients
that they might add,
or specialized flours with
different levels of protein.
So it just does
this magical thing.
And so there's
like a sponge cake,
gingerbread, all these
different baked goods that use
mashed sweet potato in them.
I really encourage
you to try it out.
It's kind of akin to how
applesauce or zucchini could,
for a quick bread, anyway,
could increase the moisture
while reducing the fat.
But sweet potatoes also
have a little bit of starch,
so you can also reduce the white
flour in some of the recipes.
- It's like a win-win-win.
Well, I want to know, what was
the most surprising thing you
learned writing this book, all
the way down your sweet potato
rabbit hole?
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
George Washington Carver
had almost as mini
sweet potato inventions
as he did peanut inventions.
JENNA TAYLOR:
[LAUGHS] Sweet potato?
Give me an example of a
sweet potato invention.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Oh, my
gosh, on the spot now--
like, in the dozens of
uses for sweet potatoes.
Everything from--
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, use, OK.
I thought you were talking
about, like, a machine-- that
runs on sweet potatoes.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Well, I guess
you could get energy from them.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, really?
Yeah, plug in, run your clock.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
He tried it, anyway.
You know, we're not running
our cars on sweet potatoes yet.
Actually, it's way better
to probably eat them.
Run yourself on them.
JENNA TAYLOR: To your body.
MARY-FRANCES HECK: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Absolutely.
Thank you so much.
MARY-FRANCES HECK:
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]